hey minimizers you're getting ready to
watch some footage from one of the
minimalist live events from the love
people use things tour if you'd like to
see us on the road visit
theminimalists.com
tour or you can find all of our live
events over at patreon.com
slash the minimalists enjoy
minimalists
howdy hello hey what's up man good to
meet you guys again you guys came here
in 2017. yes indeed you have the
opportunity to get a hug then
so we'll pass it on to all these people
as long as you like have a negative
covet test or something
definitely um so my name is jordan
jordan i have four kids
um my beautiful wife sitting over there
as well um she's a step bomb to all four
of them
um i had a question about minimalism and
owning a home yes sometimes i hear
people you know i rented an apartment
because it was easier to get rid of
everything in my home sell my house get
out of debt or anything my wife and i
have the opportunity to own two homes
right now which is great great
investment
i was curious about home ownership and
minimalism and buying the home
planning to live in it for five years
six years and then you know why people
say upgrading so just kind of curious
about what your guys's thoughts are on
homeownership and minimalism
yeah i mean
obviously we're not against
owning homes right
well you know it goes back to that
question like you have two homes and you
can you and your wife can ask yourselves
can we afford this
and if the answer is yes then by all
means i mean have a home i mean i think
that having a mortgage i mean dave
ramsey would say
which like i treat him as like the
financial
you know
guru
he would probably kill me if he heard me
call him a guru but anyway uh
you know he would say hey look like yeah
30-year mortgage that you know i'm sorry
15-year mortgage um that would be okay
to have
uh but he really would encourage you to
pay that off as soon as possible and not
accumulate any other debt especially
with a car and then definitely credit
cards and then those payday loans like
definitely don't do that
which brings me to my point of there are
some debts that are better than others
but
like josh and i are firm believers on
there's no such thing as good debt
like who is grateful
for the debt they have now i do
understand there are some people like
mark zuckerberg
who you know bought a 50 million dollar
house
and he got a 30-year mortgage on it at a
really low interest interest rate he
could have paid cash but he's got 50
million to put into the stock market and
gain seven percent year over year so
like if you're really really rich okay i
get it i mean but still i don't look at
his debt like it's good debt so you know
for me personally i i try to have as
little debt as possible but yeah i mean
owning a home um it it
it just begs that question can i afford
it and i'll tell you living in la ren is
really expensive in la
and i have went through this like okay
um can i like buy a house out in like
you know
alta dina or something somewhere way out
of you know way out of the city um maybe
i could afford that and afford that that
debt payment but i don't plan on staying
there
for 15 years now if i was planning on
staying there for at least 15 years i
would probably look into trying to buy a
home somewhere
so i rent my wife and i rent because we
look at that as really
we're each month we're paying for this
ability to kind of turn our lives around
on a dime so i think it's derek sivers
who he talks about like you know paying
for rent rather than uh paying for a
mortgage in his situation is paying for
the freedom to do what he wants when he
wants
so um yeah i mean that's what i'm doing
in la i'm renting uh but it would be a
much different situation if i was
planning on being there long term
i think it really depends on
whether or not the house is a burden or
a blessing right
and i just sold a house i owned a house
outright back in dayton ohio
which cost about the same price as a
parking spot in los angeles
and um
i owned this house outright and i rented
it every month and it was fine it wasn't
a big problem but the the psychological
weight of it because i knew i wasn't
going back to dayton at least not
anytime soon
the psychological weight of it was oh
you know what having renters being a
landlord not for me for some people
they're like yes i have a really good
friend i write about him in the book
who's living the american dream he owns
like 25 properties and he is so
passionate and he enjoys it his name is
jamar and he's in cincinnati and
man i mean it couldn't be a better
situation for him to own a house for me
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense to
be a landlord in terms of um
a mortgage yeah i'd prefer not to have
one but it's the only a debt that i
would find acceptable in my own life
by the way i'm not telling you all not
to have debt not you do whatever you
want uh you know we're not policing
anyone else's behavior right
um we are handing out certificates
though
yeah some of you aren't going to be
allowed to be
minimalists
especially if you own a home
yeah and so um
i think i think ultimately you have to
determine
man is this is this really serving me
and what i what i want serving my
outcome or am i just doing it because of
why well we're told what you should
own a home you should have a 30-year
mortgage only two countries in the world
where that's the standard
we're one of them in fact we now have
40-year mortgages
with 83-month car loans
well why are we doing this we are
enslaving our future cells for some
temporary pleasure
today and if that's what i'm doing
then
man i'm probably gonna go the other way
one other thing um
because there are no shoulds right there
are only could so you could own a home
and people hear me say this and they're
like well i should have a mortgage is
what society tells me so
obviously society's wrong so i guess
it's i shouldn't have a mortgage or own
a home that's not what i'm saying either
right
there's this great cartoon that i saw
it's a new yorker cartoon it was a
husband and wife and they're on a farm
and he looks over and he has his phone
in his hand he goes honey and they're on
their farm it's a beautiful big farm he
goes honey
i think i only like the instagram part
of owning a farm
and so if you like only the instagram
part of owning a house then maybe it
makes more sense to rent
thanks for your questions
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free